top secret binary code messages
revolutionizing the world of mathematics
and the power of a well-placed burp
these are just a few hidden traits in
The Odyssey of Futurama
Futurama was pretty much the perfect
title for an ambitious show about the
amazing world of tomorrow and yet
Creator Matt Groening had some other
names in mind that he originally liked
more on the first season DVD director's
commentary he revealed that his first
idea for the title was Aloha Mars his
other proposed option was the
significantly more pessimistic
doomsville but it sounds like nobody
else working on the show was
particularly psyched about those
possibilities the title they eventually
settled on was lifted from the 1939 to
1940 New York World's Fair as visitors
were welcomed into the World of Tomorrow
many of them lined up for the General
Motors Pavilion and its exhibit called
Futurama which offered a glimpse into
the far-off futuristic year of 1960.
appropriately enough on the show's pilot
episode a cryogenic facility employee
references that exhibits slogan
welcome to the world of tomorrow
why do you always have to say it that
way on The Simpsons Matt Groening's
first show several of the main
characters were named after graining's
immediate family for example Homer and
Marge's namesakes are graining's parents
Futurama's lead character Philip J fry
was also named after granny's father as
Philip was his middle name when
production began on Futurama in 1998 two
of the most important roles were locked
down before voice recording began for
fry producers picked Charlie Schlatter a
veteran actor who is best known for
playing the title role in the
short-lived TV adaptation of Ferris
Bueller as for Leela Nicole Sullivan got
the job at the time she was a breakout
star on The Late Night Fox sketch comedy
show Mad TV but then suddenly producers
changed their minds and decided to
replace both of those actors Billy West
who is best known at the time for his
work on the Howard Stern Show and Ren
and Stimpy stepped in as fry and taking
over as Leela was Katie Seagal who was
best known as matriarch Peg Bundy on
Fox's long-running sitcom Married With
Children
Bender bending Rodriguez the show's
resident sociopathic alcoholic robot is
perhaps Futurama's most beloved
character a big part of that is thanks
to John DiMaggio's excellent Voice work
the actor discussed his inspiration
during an appearance for his signature
character on the Kevin Pollock Chat Show
he took a little bit from cowboy movie
actor Slim Pickens who's probably best
known among comedy fans for Blazing
Saddles and Dr Strangelove DiMaggio was
also inspired by drunk bar flies and a
little bit from a character that a
college friend once performed called
Charlie the sausage lover DiMaggio
initially auditioned for the role of
Professor Farnsworth with his unique
raspy blend of surliness gregariousness
and self-importance he didn't get that
role but he managed to book Bender using
the same voice glad I'm not him whoever
he is Dr John Zoidberg is a wholly
original creation a man of
contradictions he's lobster-esque but
also human-like he's a doctor and yet
also somehow poor best of all he's a
creature of the 31st Century from
another planet to explicably talks like
an old Vaudeville comedian Billy West
pulled from two major old-timey
Inspirations when putting together
zoidberg's voice actors George Jessel
and Lou Jacoby that background
definitely provides a Jewish Yiddish
flavor to the character which West
thought was appropriate considering the
traditionally Jewish Berg suffix in his
last name the Zoid part of the name
meanwhile is a futuristic alien sounding
word that has personal significance for
Futurama producer and writer David X
Cohen it comes from a computer game
named Zoid which Cohen created when he
was just a kid he submitted it to
brooderbund software but they ended up
rejecting it they also spelled his name
wrong in their rejection letter which
sounds like something that could have
happened to Zoidberg on an episode of
Futurama the late great Phil Hartman
specialized in playing characters both
obnoxious and oblivious such as Bill
McNeil on news radio he also voiced the
sleazy lawyer Lionel huts and the washed
up actor Troy McClure on The Simpsons so
it makes perfect sense that he was cast
to provide the voice of the obnoxious
Captain Kirk ask Captain Zapp Brannigan
on Futurama but then in 1998 tragedy
struck when Hartman was murdered by his
wife Brynn after his passing Billy West
stepped into the role he once had a
conversation with Hartman about their
shared love of old-time radio announcers
who had big booming voices and an
inflated sense of self-importance so
West ended up playing zap in that style
as a tribute to Hartman you disgust me
go on Futurama producers really wanted
the Beastie Boys one of the most popular
rap groups of the 20th century to play
themselves in the 31st Century they made
it on but it didn't work out exactly as
they'd hoped the plan was to have them
appear the same way that many
contemporary celebrities guest starred
on Futurama as disembodied heads kept
alive in jars over the centuries but
according to the DVD commentary for the
episode hell is other robots when writer
producers Ken Keeler and David X Cohen
went to New York to meet with the
beasties they never managed to connect
eventually the band members recorded
their vocals separately while Adam
adrock horvitz and Mike Diamond recorded
their tracks without any fuss but Adam
MCA yaok had a scheduling conflict so
adrock just did his lines for him even
after all that the group wasn't entirely
happy with the material that the
Futurama writers had prepared in the
finished episode The beasties perform a
portion of their hit song Sabotage
acapella they were initially asked to
perform you gotta fight for your right
to party in this style but they refused
nevertheless there were apparently no
hard feelings lingering afterward as the
group later gave a bit of a shout out to
Futurama on their 2009 single too many
rappers
Futurama was primarily a comedy but some
episodes would occasionally touch on
Fry's sadness and sense of loss from
being stuck in the future the 2002
episode Jurassic Bark is perhaps the
most notable example in this regard
while visiting a museum fry discovers
the fossilized remains of his dog
Seymour Professor Farnsworth then tells
him that he could feasibly take some of
Seymour's DNA and create a clone during
the cloning process fry learns that
Seymour lived to be 15. he figures that
after he disappeared in 1999 his Pooch
must have lived a long happy life
without him but then the saddest
flashback in the history of TV occurs as
it's revealed that Seymour actually
didn't move on instead he waited for fry
outside the pizzeria where he used to
work for more than a decade the episode
ends with Seymour closing his eyes
passing away and every viewer sobbing
uncontrollably somehow this episode
could have been even sadder as revealed
on the DVD commentary the writers toyed
around with the idea of fry finding the
remains of his mother and then
considering But ultimately dismissing
the possibility of cloning her he's just
upset because our boy's missing come on
the older from rat lead us to Phillip
the 2010 Futurama episode The Prisoner
of Benda takes the ever popular body
swap Trope to absurge new heights
Professor Farnsworth invents a machine
that allows him and his intern Amy to
place each other's minds into one
another's bodies then the rest of the
Planet Express crew gets involved using
the machine to put their brains into
each other's bodies to fulfill various
whims and goals alas there's a catch as
the machine can't be used twice with the
same two people in order to get
everybody's brains back to their
original bodies the Harlem Globetrotters
come to the rescue with a mathematical
theorem in the Futurama Universe the
Globetrotters are not only amazing
basketball players but also brilliant
scientists and mathematicians another
brilliant mathematician is the episode's
writer Ken Keeler who holds a doctorate
in math from Harvard to find a
mathematically accurate way to switch
everybody's brains back into the correct
body Keeler had to devise a brand new
algorithm-based mathematical serum we
won't overwhelm you with the specifics
but you can trust that Keeler put in the
work to prove the viability of this
complicated plot
over the years Billy West has
consistently proven himself to be one of
the most prolific voice actors of his
generation on Futurama alone he's voiced
more than 40 different characters
including fry Professor Farnsworth Dr
Zoidberg zap Branigan and dozens of
others because of this he often plays
every character in a given scene
requiring him to act opposite himself
multiple times over it would be
difficult enough to record each voice
separately while hearing the playback of
his other performances but West
apparently tends to bounce back and
forth between the various voices in real
time to play all of the characters in a
single recording session one of his
co-stars Phil Lamar was amazed when he
saw West acting opposite himself in this
way while recording the show's very
first episode so the entire scene was
Billy and we all just sat in the room
and he did the entire thing in one tank
three different voices with the success
looking bad and Better Call Saul Bob
Kirk has enjoyed a meteoric rise to
become one of the hottest dramatic
actors in the industry but before his
pivot to prestige TV he was beloved in
comedy circles particularly for the
sketch series Mr show as well as a
stints on other sketch shows like
Saturday Night Live and the Ben Stiller
show and he's not the only member of his
family known for making people laugh as
his younger brother Bill worked
alongside him as a producer on Mr Show
before joining the Matt graning stable
Bill Odenkirk has worked on The Simpsons
Futurama and disenchantment as both a
writer and a producer he joined the
Simpsons as a supervising producer for
the show's 15th season while he was
involved with Futurama as early as
season 2. this has afforded the Odin
Kirk Brothers even more opportunities to
collaborate as Bob voiced a character
named Chaz in the Futurama episode The
why of fry and he played a mob lawyer in
The Simpsons episode The Fat Blue Line
on Futurama there are two distinct alien
languages that can be spotted on screen
at various times at first glance the
symbols may appear to be gibberish but
they actually form a language that can
be decoded via a substitution Cipher
into readable English the Genesis of
these alien languages extends back to a
time before Futurama even existed as
David X Cohen explained two wired in
2013 we realized at first in The
Simpsons and later carrying on the
tradition in Futurama that we could hide
these jokes in the background that were
called Freeze Frame jokes we tried to
cash in on every bit of real estate in
space and time in the show fans were
able to decode the first alien language
almost instantly the second version was
more complex and although it was
eventually decoded by some dedicated
fans it took more legwork to figure out
Cohen has revealed that there was a
third language ready to go but they
never ended up implementing it because
it was too complicated and too time
consuming the creative team concluded
that it would go uncracked for years and
that decoding it would require the use
of more Advanced Computers than what was
currently on them Market
Futurama is densely packed with jokes on
top of jokes so it's fitting that
co-creator David X Cohen's name is also
a joke of sorts as it turns out the X in
his name doesn't stand for anything nor
is it even his real middle initial which
is actually s when he was joining the
writer's Guild of America there was
already a David S Cohen and duplicate
names aren't allowed in the guild as
Cohen recalled during a Reddit AMA I
decided that once I was going phony I
would take the phoniest letter of all
Cohen also picked X because he thought
it was cool and that it sounded the most
sci-fi back when he was writing for The
Simpsons he wasn't yet in the writer's
Guild and was therefore allowed to be
credited as David S Cohen then when he
switched his middle initial for Futurama
it led to some confusion over whether or
not he was even the same person who
worked on The Simpsons
while Futurama certainly has its fair
share of crafts and lowbrow comedy it
also features plenty of elevated humor
as well as a notable amount of
complicated math and science one of the
main reasons the show works as well as
it does is because it takes its sci-fi
Concepts seriously this approach was
inspired by many sources with one of the
most obscure being the late polish
author stanislav Lem Lem was a renowned
sci-fi writer who published novels short
stories poetry and essays from the 1940s
to the 1990s he's perhaps best known as
the writer of the 1961 novel Solaris
which has been adapted into multiple
movies his work served as a significant
influence on David X Cohen who told
wired in 2014. my mom was a voracious
science fiction reader so actually
that's where I got my love of Science
Fiction and some of the books I found
lying around when I was a kid were the
stanislav books Cohen went on to explain
how surreal and funny the short stories
were and until they did have a big
influence on me especially as far as the
idea that robots could be characters so
Bender being kind of most human
characters on Futurama I think does owe
a little bit to stanislav Lem
Futurama occasionally Ventures into the
Anthology format one of the most notable
examples is naturama which is presented
as a Sci-Fi nature documentary with the
main characters appearing as
anthropomorphic animals the second
segment in this episode the penta Island
tortoise refers to a specific species of
tortoise from the Galapagos Islands the
episode is dedicated to the memory of
Lonesome George the last living tortoise
of a species who died two years before
this half hour aired the character of
lonely Hubert is a clear nod to George
who caught the imagination of the world
after he was discovered by a Hungarian
scientist on Pinta Island in 1971.
George passed away in 2012 at the
tortoise breeding and rearing Center on
Santa Cruz Island his exact age was
unknown though scientists estimated that
he was about a hundred years old that
might sound like quite the senior animal
but giant tortoises of this type can
actually live for twice that long
Leela and Amy are two of the most
crucial members of the Planet Express
team they have a few traits in common
but their core personalities are
drastically different it may be hard to
imagine today but their personalities
were originally the other way around Amy
was written to be a tough tomboy type
who served as the cruise mechanic and
wore coveralls rather than her trademark
pink sweatsuit while Leela was the
softer of the two in the original pilot
script by the time casting was underway
though it was clear that a change needed
to be made Lauren Tom wound up being
cast as Amy but there was one big issue
she wasn't a good fit for the character
as she was initially written that's not
really my Persona that I put out luckily
Matt Groening was willing to Workshop
the character and retool Amy's
personality to better suit Tom they were
able to keep all the plans they had for
Amy by transferring her rougher
attributes to Leela which ultimately
worked better for everyone as Tom
recalled they made Amy a little bit
softer kind of free with her love they
made Leela the tougher one when Katie
Seagal came on that also fit perfectly
with her her persona Futurama wouldn't
have been the same without David X
Cohen's input but there was a time when
it looked like the show would have to
move on without him soon after
production on the show began Cohen found
himself overwhelmed by the job's heavy
workload the tight schedule and the high
pressure demands the stress reached such
a boiling point that he ended up walking
away for a time as he recalled to sci-fi
online a few months into the production
of Futurama I got so exhausted that I
couldn't do the job anymore and I
actually quit for about four days
luckily for fans of the show Cohen was
able to keep his cool and power through
all the trials and tribulations the
demanding production schedule was so
extreme that the creators jokingly
invented an eighth day of the week
called learns day to be able to get all
of their work done on time that
eventually led to the creation of
blern's ball the show's jazzed up
version of baseball
except for the word blur and that was
complete gibberish Bender's apartment is
a central location in Futurama that
winds up becoming Fry's home as well
when he moves into the spacious closet
which is several times larger than the
rest of the apartment the apartment
building is specifically designed for
robots and all the door numbers are
written in binary vendors apartment
number for example is zero zero one zero
zero one zero zero on its own this is a
simple visual gag but the joke goes
deeper for anyone willing to put in a
little extra effort when the binary is
converted into a standard decimal number
Bender's apartment number is 36 but
there's still one more conversion
required to arrive at the final punch
line this last step requires knowledge
of the official ASCII table which is the
standardized Computing chart that breaks
down how letters and special characters
are processed by computers to simplify
binary uses zeros and ones to create all
numbers and ASCII then uses numbers to
create all other characters that are
outputted by computers 36 in the ASCII
table corresponds to the dollar sign
which is perfectly appropriate
appropriate for Bender's greedy
money-hungry personality
Hermes Conrad is the bureaucrat who
serves as the Planet Express Cruise
accountant he notably has a Jamaican
accent and the show frequently
references his Caribbean Heritage this
has included entire story lines
spotlighting his journey as a contender
in Olympic limbo competitions but as
hard as it may be to imagine today
Hermes almost wasn't from Jamaica at all
when Phil Lamar first landed the part of
Hermes he leaned far more heavily into
the nerdy accountant side of the
character this approach utilized Lamar's
natural American accent and he even
recorded the first three episodes of the
show like this but it was clear that it
wasn't quite firing on all cylinders
Matt Groening was the one who had the
idea to switch things up as Lamar
recalled the Vanity Fair adding the
accent gave the character another
dimension added depth because all of a
sudden instead of just writing
accountant jokes they were writing
Jamaican jokes Lamar happily changed his
approach and the character finally felt
right moving forward had Matt not
suggested that
I probably wouldn't be sitting here I
probably wouldn't have made it past
episode four as the voice of Bender and
numerous smaller characters John
DiMaggio has been an indispensable part
of Futurama since the beginning and yet
somehow the Hulu reboot version of the
show nearly moved forward without him
the rest of the main cast had already
agreed to return but DiMaggio was
holding out for higher pay he considered
the rates being offered to the cast by
Hulu's parent company Disney to be
woefully insufficient and he wasn't just
trying to get his own pay increase but
also those of his co-stars when news of
the dispute broke fans were up in arms
about one of their favorite voice actors
potentially being replaced DiMaggio
revealed that the plan to produce the
show without him was to have Bender's
voice change from episode to episode
with different guest stars taking turns
with the character ultimately though
DiMaggio ended up returning and the full
cast was thus reunited once again but
the situation wasn't resolved as
amicably as possible DiMaggio's return
had many fans thinking he successfully
landed the pay raise that he was after
but he actually didn't receive any
additional money in the end according to
him Disney was completely unwilling to
negotiate create or offer Fair
compensation so he chose to return to
Futurama simply out of love for the
series
I deserve that Futurama was co-created
by Matt Groening and David X Cohen
though the former is sometimes totally
lost when the show gets complicated many
of the geekier references go over his
head and he freely admits that much of
the hard Science and Mathematics is just
gibberish to him but this is part of why
he and Cohen makes such a great team
Cohen and most of the other writers are
all experts on the show's far-ranging
subject matter particularly producer Ken
Keeler who has a PHD in applied math in
a 2013 interview with the Los Angeles
Times graining admitted that he has no
idea how space travel in the Futurama
Universe actually works as he explained
originally we planned to have the
spaceship powered by the MW Drive which
is Magic Wand all science fiction has
that magic wand where you can travel
through galaxies very quickly and
instead David had a friend who had a
theory that you could slow down the
speed of light and therefore make things
faster graining went along with it
choosing to trust his writing staff and
their knowledge of theoretical space
travel and advanced mathematics saying
I'm never understood it but that's what
happens and the ship is fueled by dark
matter whatever that is Again David
Cohen could explain as could all the
writing staff except me
there's been a ton of overlap between
The Simpsons and Futurama over the years
which has extended into the show's comic
series and other related media but
what's perhaps less well known is the
extensive connective tissue between
Futurama and the animated Netflix show
disenchantment which was also co-created
by Matt Groening and utilizes David X
Cohen as a writer and producer
disenchantment is littered with hidden
jokes and Easter eggs including many
references to Futurama grinding
co-created disenchantment with Josh
Weinstein who also worked on The
Simpsons and Futurama as a writer and
producer Weinstein spoke with wiretap in
2021 about the Futurama references that
he snuck into disenchantment and
confirmed that there are still more
connections left to be discovered as he
divulged fans started to realize certain
things like Dreamland is the ancestral
home of the elves but there are other
things people have not realized at all
that have to do with the Deep canonical
Arc Weinstein also dispelled one
particular fan theory that could lead
viewers to expect a reveal that's never
coming as he explained people have this
complex theory that disenchantment takes
place in that future that we saw with
fry and The Time Machine and that is not
true this is the first time I'm saying
that because I love fan theories
box Amy Wong is known for occasionally
burping quite loudly but belching on
command is something that her voice
actor Lauren Tom has trouble with rather
than using a stock burp sound effect or
faking it in some other way the Futurama
team has utilized some of Tom's co-stars
John DiMaggio has filled in as her burp
double as has Maurice lamarche who
voices several characters on the show
most notably Kiff for La Marsh burping
is no casual exercise he takes this
bodily function quite seriously and has
devised his own carefully crafted method
for delivering the most effective
on-command burps possible this method
also extends to other bodily noises such
as vomiting as he employs an element of
tuvan throat singing to produce an
especially guttural sound lamarche is
actually somewhat famous in the voice
acting world for his fake burping
abilities and Amy is far from the only
character he served as the burp double
for specifically he's also provided
belches for wacko on Animaniacs and Will
Ferrell as Buddy the elf in elf
did you hear that
[Music]